ALHARGE OF THE
INVESTIGATION  IENS  CULMINATIO1
D A
MOL D THE F
OF "THE  ENQUIRER."
PROTECT PREDATORS JOINEDEN FARR
YORKER."
HATIER" WI D THI,
TRIEM TO BUY IHER.CLEA MY REPOR
AEL COHEE
"TIRER" AN I BELIEVE
THAT THERE
ONGOING ARRANGEMENT TO HH
NE AND KILS IS
M THAT W
UNTE ABOUT
TR SO THE CATCH ANKIU ORG DAVID
PUBLISHER OFW  THE
"THE ENQUIRER"D AN VE
ALLIANCE WIT
DAVICKIERE
TH H BY
WHH  GT
UNFLATNGLY TDRSTT DONALD TRUMP
RIGHTS TSTIE
ENTA EEN MUZING
IN POSSESON
THD INSTEAD OFLTT
TR "THE ENQUIRER
N ITT T OF MRTT
CEO OF MANY,
"THE ENQE THIS
H SPDERSON SPOKE WITKATHE "P"
MODEL WHO SA S AMPD FOR
SILENCE.
I'M GOIN O
E EXPLAINS HERITH THIS CATCH AN
KILLCESS.
HAS YOURERAN
A CAAN
>> FROM WHAT I'M LEARNING KILLS
STMEDY LIKUT OR HAVE AT AND THER
>>T THAT'S
>> WHYYOUAEDTORY>> NOW GOINGHE.E
T TO HURT HIM.>> YOU THINKRSHE
O RUNS AMI IDONALD TRUMP? CORRE.
>> S
DAVID ERP
LIKE
"THE ENQUIRER" GET OUALL? W TH
RED TOY E FRIENDSHIP WITH TRUMP
N HOWARD, THS ACCORDING  MANY N
COA
COATTAILS, AS WELL A TERE WAS A
OFOW TT
RE DOING WAS GOING
TO LOOADMEWAS SAID IINTERNAL TEP
ANE  THE  ALMOSTR WORD
CONSEQUENCES.
ER DID MEET WITHUTORS IN TCAITK
REPORTEDLY TESTIFI T
WHD O YOU .
THINK HE MIGHT BE  T
PROVIDE?
PATS AMI INCLUDINGING ONUS
YING TO NG STATEMENTS D HAVE YOG
HO ADMIGED IN THAPORTIN SUME IT
WITH FEDERALRO
INDIVIDUALS ARE
JOHNS NOT NEW INFORME FACTS ART.
YOU KNOW, THEY WERY  "THE WALL
URY POREPORTINONTHE RECORD IS KD
PEEKER SO ITAND PEE
REINFORCE IT.
THE QUESTION IS IT G
TO RESONATE WITH A
ESPECIALLY WITOV
THUNDATION OTHSET GOE LITICALLY?
THISS T TOT  WORDS
DONALD TRUMP RN HE THE AMO HE'L
BE ABLE TO FUNF TH